for angela merkel this is the sweetest
victory of all her party the christian
democrats have just scored their best
election result for over 20 years
a day later the cdu is still celebrating
still mackel remained low-key at a
post-election news conference she paid
tribute to her outgoing coalition
partners
i'd like to thank our current coalition
partners the free democrats i'm sorry
they fell short of entering the
bundestag
whom will merkel choose as her coalition
partner this time around the social
democrats or the greens
a day after her win merkel won't commit
the chancellor has fended off question
after question on her coalition choices
journalists even asked her if her outfit
hinted a preferred coalition partner
you won't believe it i stood in front of
my closet this morning and thought i
can't wear red bright greens out i wore
blue yesterday
so what am i going to do
at the same time mackel has indicated
she's keener on red on the social
democrats
i've already made contact with the
chairman of the spd
he understandably asked us to wait until
after they've held a party meeting on
friday
however merkel says she doesn't want to
rush into a deal
and the social democrats are in no rush
to make a pact with merkel either
they would be the smaller party in her
government and merkel's christian
democrats have just scored an
overwhelming victory
isn't standing in line for government we
haven't handed in an application mrs
merkel destroyed her last coalition
partner so we're not keen to step in as
the replacement
the spd governed with merkel once
between 2005 and 2009
but that cost them votes
merkel took credit for the good
decisions and the social democrats were
seen as junior partners
the spd left wing says that needs to be
avoided in the future
we ruled out a coalition with a left
party we can't change our minds now but
this is the last election where we'll do
that
the most likely outcome is a
conservative social democrat coalition
the spd leadership know that
but they'll want to drive as hard a
bargain as they can
you